hey welcome back to the just pearly
things YouTube channel no I not Pearl my
name is Christine Grace and today I'm
going to be covering the PE Daily Show
PE is back in the States I believe she's
gone to Miami so make sure you stay
tuned for all of the content that's
going to be coming over from there but
it is business as usual here in London
so today I am going to be covering the
treachery debauchery going on in today's
world so let's get straight into it
today the first topic on the list today
is Candice Owens discussing the trans
Community now I'm aware this is always a
very hot topic I'm a Candace Owens fan
so yeah let's take a look at what she's
got to offer us today you're demented
homophobic and transphobic rhetoric and
rants just further prove our point that
we have to fight loudly to be respected
the reason that lgbtqia plus rates are
so high in this country it's because
there are people like you who make us
feel like we don't
belong is there a question in there or a
speech you got to ask a question buddy
how do you and how do you think other
people with your beliefs respond to the
fact that your hateful home rhetoric
cost the lives of queer children every
single day on average every 45 seconds
okay so this is just going to be a pure
Boogeyman you're pretending that someone
committed Su because of Candace Owens
you've got no facts here I sat down with
a man named wal High who was convinced
to chop his pis off after your community
told him that there was something wrong
with him because he had confusion why
was he trans because he was molested
when he was 4 years old by his uncle
rather than being sat down and spoken to
by a psychologist he was handed hormone
pills and he eventually chopped off his
penis rates go up after they transition
after they transition and canis Owens
wasn't the one that chopped their Disc
Off look there's a there's a couple of
points to take away from here firstly I
I think it's great that she calls him
out and ask is there actually a question
in there because a lot of people within
this community just want to scream at
what they think the problem is instead
of actually looking at data and
statistics and coming to a logical
conclusion for what's actually going on
the truth is she's not actually spitting
anything hateful she's not proclaiming
anything hateful towards these people in
fact a lot of people on the conservative
side of things are acknowledging that
these people need help the problem lies
in the fact that in their Community
they're saying this is an identity thing
this is just who we are they almost want
their mental illness to be affirmed and
that's why they call it affirming care
but it's like is that really helping
anyone when you're affirming someone's
mental illness like if you've got an
anorexic person and you affirm their
mental illness so if you tell someone
who's anorexic that yes you are in fact
fat when they're not how is that helping
them and and that's the problem and I
think the example of the guy that she
spoke to is is a perfect example for how
these things can be really really
dangerous I mean let alone the fact that
we've got the people in this community
advocating for children to be chemically
and sometimes physically castrated
that's not doing any good for anyone and
it's absolute facts that suicide rates
go up after transition I think I mean
I'm speculating here I don't have any
evidence for this but I think of course
it's going to go up after transition
because they're likely going to feel the
same but their body has completely
changed and often you can't go back on
these decisions they're permanent life
altering decisions and yet they're still
miserable inside of course it's going to
be a miserable place to be uncomfortable
in your own skin whatever that may look
like any kind of body dysmorphia
dysphoria whatever it is it's going to
be uncomfortable it's going to be a
harsh place to be and the answer is with
inside yourself because it's a cognitive
problem if you can't acknowledge the
biological facts of your body that's a
problem in your mind that's got nothing
to do with what's going on on the
outside so I think she did a great job
here of putting him straight and saying
look you need to look at at the facts
it's not me who's forcing them to cut
their dicks off as she puts it and quite
rightly so these people are self
mutilating themselves they're doing it
to themselves and then they want to
blame someone else for their own mental
problems and and that's not the way
forward the only way to deal with any
kind of mental illness first step is
self-accountability and acknowledging
that you have a problem but these people
don't want to acknowledge that it's a
problem even the NHS website doesn't
claim that it's a mental illness anymore
so really what can we do we can just try
and educate them but unfortunately
there's a a large group of people that
he's just admitted they want to scream
really loudly and they think that's the
only way to to get anything done instead
of perhaps having a genuine conversation
and and trying to find a way forward but
hey what can we do